in drachenzähmen leicht gemacht
neben wikinger und drachen in
freundschaft
trassem rennen zum verbinden der
leidenschaft
fix die hauptfigur will nicht in die
kriegerischen fußstapfen seines vaters
regelung anführer des clans wäre er ins
lieber die freiheit des von seinem brach
er will nicht kampf sondern frieden er
ist eben anders als die anderen schöpfer
dieser drachen und filmfiguren ist der
schweizer simon otto-chef animateur bei
dreamworks kurz zu besuch in der alten
heimat findet er bei bruno webers
fantasiefiguren in g t con inspiration
sich anders fühlen als alle anderen
wie der held seines neuen drachen films
das kennt simon otto gut der film
erzählt auch ein klein wenig seine
eigene geschichte
oft ist thema im kino empfehlen dass das
der andersdenkende vor überzeugt dass
das erich dass er die richtige richtung
und das hat viel damit zu tun dass
filmemacher autor maler und zeichner mit
einem 2 1 wenn sie einfach für mich also
auf dass du aus schweizer vom landvolk
in troy mich wovor schritt machbar ist
die shuttle astronaut oder tücher auch
weiter bis sich so abstrakt es gibt kein
sein weg führte von gommiswald über eine
animation schule interesse
heute bestimmt er wie die fantasie
figuren auf der leinwand lebendig als
chef arthur kennt er seine geschöpfe in
und auswendig bereit deshalb aus dem
regisseur unterhaltungspotenzial unsere
szene versucht umsetzung also mit
regisseur richtzeit
derrick rose ganz klar die regale und
seit 17 jahren lebt sie motto
mittlerweile mit familie in los angeles
doch für california dreaming bleibt
wenig zeit in der kalifornischen
traumfabrik sind immer drachen zu wenden
intrigen geht's aber nicht ersetzen
ganz krass man sich dem fernseher gehört
überholen große konkurrenzkampf heisst
so viel blut würde den job neben gern
aber nicht machen
das muss wieder hinterfragen und neue
sachen probieren und risiken und das
sind sachen jeder machen ich muss
besiegen
in simon autos kindheit in gommiswald
fehlte das kreative umfeld künstler oder
animateur war kein eigentlicher beruf
seine eltern unterstützten seine träume
dennoch und gaben ihm einiges mit auf
den weg
24 10 sekunden oder 24 bilder mit dem
computer des chromebooks schon glauben
was sie sich von der momentanen uns
richten das künstlerische und teilweise
schon ihr vater simon atom kann drachen
zeichnen und auf seinem weg hatte auch
etliche gezählt scheinbar leicht ganz
wie im film